intentemos calcular 3 por 32 una forma
de resolverlo es intentar describirlo
así que me gustaría que lo hiciéramos de
tal forma que el número más grande quede
arriba que en este caso es 32 y re
escribiremos el número más pequeño justo
debajo de él el número más pequeño tiene
un solo dígito es un número que solo
tiene unidades así que lo pondremos
debajo del número más grande en el lugar
de las unidades entonces pondremos al 3
justo aquí y claro no olvidemos el signo
de multiplicación básicamente esta es
otra forma de decir lo mismo podemos
leerlo como 32 por 3 o 32 veces 3 y esto
tiene exactamente el mismo valor que 3
por 32 no importa el orden en el que
multipliquemos ahora intentemos
calcularlo una vez más esta no es la
única forma de realizar esta
multiplicación existen otras pero bueno
me gustaría que pienses por qué esta
forma funciona
bueno empezaremos con el 3 aquí abajo y
lo multiplicaremos por cada uno de los
dígitos de 32 primero multiplicaremos 3
por 2 bueno 3 por 2 sabemos por nuestras
tablas de multiplicar e incluso puede
resolverla sin saber las tablas de
multiplicar
sabemos que 3 por 2 es 6 entonces 3 por
2 es igual a 6 y lo escribiremos en el
lugar de las unidades
ahora encontremos cuánto es 3 x 3 una
vez más sabemos que tres por tres es
nueve como estamos multiplicando el
lugar de las decenas entonces lo
escribiré en el lugar de las decenas de
esta forma y ya está
tenemos que 32 por 3 es 96 y realmente
te invito a pensar por qué funciona esto
y te voy a dar una pequeña pista
recuerda 3 x 32 es lo mismo que 3 por 30
más 3 por 2
básicamente esta forma de verlo es lo
mismo que el proceso que hicimos a la
derecha 3 x 2 6 y 3 por 30 es 90 después
lo sumamos 90 + 6 es igual a 96 listo